alors imagine maintenant tu sois là
assis et qui est des gens dans la rue
qui te pose toutes les questions qu'ils
veulent et imagine que ce soit laurent
baffie le reporter tu es prêt à finir
20e en sachet d'entre eux sont tués près
ouais sico starr de stars
il est là sur le plateau ils vous
regardent vous avez une question à lui
poser
eux non sont proches tous ici s'il fait
prochain qu'on dira un olympia quelque
chose un prochain spectacle
alors oui pierre il vient de faire
l'olympia et non attends c'est pas
déroger des récents jeux ça tu as
forcément ensuite où ta carrière s'est
fait la malle prix trouver notre
question la suisse est bonne chance
je prends pas des mongoliens pierre je
pense que je trouve alors soit pas celle
non plus trouvé une question
intelligente j'ai pas qui sera déposé je
suis désolé pour la peta ok alors alors
allez c'est pas de moi j'ai rien à lui
dire vu que ma soeur c'est une [ __ ]
j'ai rien à lui dire pourquoi ya pas
plus originales
ils font semble beaucoup trop
l'influencent de jolis attendait non
c'est pas une [ __ ] jedermann
questions à se poser
ça peut pas te perds toujours pierre une
question mais je croyais la [ __ ] va
sortir du champ pierre monsieur ben
voila merci moi j'ai pas je vois pas ce
que pourrait lui poser comme question
elle étonne pas et me dit je crois qu
est-ce qui fait cesser dans le mot
sexuelle il est en larmes vous avez
gagné bravo
ok merci mais ça détend laruns je sais
pas je savais pas que pourrait poser
c'est qu'ils trouvent ces conneries en
écoutant des blaireaux comme vous une
idée bien jouer garçon je me demande où
liessies seul trou attendait parce qu'il
me parle dans le casque la non pierre
c'est pas une vieille [ __ ] madame te
connais pas tout le monde n'est pas
obligé non parce que vous le connaissez
pas alors je n'en sois pas aux lieux
pierre je veux dire moi je te connais
pas c'est tout c'est un corps est ce que
vous dites là je connais pas la personne
en question
c'est pourquoi tu vois bien voilà on l'a
mal pris c'est pas très correct de ta
part alors madame possède une question
là je pense pas de questions les gens
qui sont corrects je ne permets pas à
soi disant monsieur chez pas comment la
qui se permettent de dire qu'à 85 ans
met une [ __ ] c'est honteux
d'accord avec vous
il me dit vous dire qu'il n'a pas dit
[ __ ] non non on attendait ce que je
dis il a dit il n'a pas dit [ __ ] il a
dit vieille [ __ ] et pamiers et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu